the luxurious rock anissa development
overlooks the southern coast of a visa
Hamburg interior designer yan Vickers
has a holiday home here a mixture of
traditional finca and modern
architecture hello either nice to see
you come on in John Vickers is house
occupies a palatial 360 square meters
there are expansive views from every
room and plenty of space for his
collection of unusual furniture like
this chair by architect Frank Gehry
dzine does house had such design kind of
as you see the house has no entry way
you land right inside it it was built
with a holiday mood in mind with this
sea views a different life the life of
freedom you have in a holiday home I
uni- on this feely indomie it's here's
the view from the sofa seems to go on
forever there's no need for a television
here
this man found Zia this is my television
my panorama television kilometers wide
it's always changing Stanley fix it
justice the weather changes life out on
the sea changes and it's incredibly
soothing no amber winked his favorite
spot is the 160 square meter Terrace
from the pool there's a view over to the
neighboring island of formentera Vickers
loves to stand here with his binoculars
looking out toward the horizon an
interior designer by profession he has a
passion for rare items of furniture he
bought these three tree root chairs back
from the Philippines and turned this
floor slab into a table do you look
front here Charles the back wall of this
outdoor shower came from a palace in
rajasthan just done yeah edens amid some
collectors are all a bit crazy they
can't leave things where they are you
just want to have things less encouraged
adolescent convulse needs and then I got
that way through my work because these
things have a certain aesthetic appeal
they can add something to an interior
give st Tasha right so hard easy
naturally hindi I'm legitimate I'm
blinkin the living room leads directly
to the bedroom the concept of open
living is in evidence here there's no
separate bathroom and the wash basin is
at the back of the bed cristiana Vickers
the designers wife is responsible for
the art in the house for the walls she
predominantly shows photographs
including portraits of Spanish painter
Pablo Picasso and Italian actress sofia
Loren the living room is decorated with
african teen art made from discarded
objects found on the streets
how about a new foam these little
sculptures have a form and they have a
soul they're made by hand with great
imagination and that fascinates me
Martha well that's lets me in me
daylight floods into the stairwell
through a skylight and in the basement
the designer has a little office where
he sometimes sketches ideas for new
projects he's somewhat ambivalent about
working went on holiday the fits and
Tyga after tests I can't just spend two
weeks sipping gin and tonics on the
terrace or going to the beach every day
in x 20 value in that respect it's
always been motivated to work here and I
found clients here I have projects here
I'm building something right now but I
wouldn't say I find it easy to work here
after all he isn't here to work he's
here to get away from the hustle and
bustle of everyday urban life and he
couldn't have picked a better place to
do it
you